the forests of Madagascar are filled
with some of the world's most unusual
species chameleons crawl through the
trees and over strange volcanic
formations the carnivorous fossa hunts
rodents birds and ring-tailed lemurs and
perhaps the weirdest of all are the
fat-tailed drawer flemers with long
tails and enormous eyes
these nocturnal primates only weigh
about 160 grams and live on a diet of
fruits insects and small animals but
that's only for half the year
for the other six or seven months during
the forest's dry season these lemurs
hibernate in tree holes living off the
fat stores in their tail
their body temperature can fluctuate by
as much as 20 degrees Celsius as the
temperature outside their nests Rises
and falls
their heart rate breath rate and brain
activity levels also drop precipitously
and while hibernation is in no way the
same as sleep hibernation can actually
lead to sleep deprivation these little
lemurs look pretty dead to the world
in fact scientists recently discovered
that two other species of dwarf lemur
living in the High Altitude forests of
Eastern Madagascar hibernate in
underground holes protecting themselves
from near freezing temperatures
when the scientists uncovered their
Burrows they found tightly curled up
balls of fur the Lemurs deep in
hibernation
these miniature lemurs are the only
known species of primate to hibernate
but this seasonal switch to a decreased
metabolism and reduced body temperature
is widespread across the animal kingdom
we see it in freshwater turtles ground
squirrels bats and of course Bears it's
an essential adaptation allowing species
to survive frigid Winters and reduced
availability of food not only that but
species that hibernate actually have
longer life spans than species of
similar sizes that don't hibernate
humankind has been aware of animals
ability to hibernate for thousands of
years going all the way back to ancient
Greece and Aristotle but we're still
unraveling the mysteries of how they do
it without losing muscle mass bone
density and brain cells
Bears can survive without food for
months at a time and some species of
turtle go for over 100 days without
breathing
how do these animals manage such
remarkable Feats where did hibernation
even come from in their evolutionary
history and could humans someday manage
the same thing
the story of hibernation begins hundreds
of millions of years ago when Earth's
land masses were all clumped together in
one supercontinent called Pangea during
this time a strange animal roamed the
region that would become Antarctica and
spread as far as present-day India and
southern Africa the listrosaurus was a
four-legged forager with tusks in its
upper jaw generally growing to the size
of a pig but sometimes reaching two and
a half meters in length they are
distantly related to Modern mammals
although the planet was much warmer 250
million years ago the southern tip of
Pangea was still in the Antarctic Circle
and experienced long stretches without
sunlight every year
when researchers compared fossils of the
listrosaurus found in Antarctica versus
those found further north they made a
surprising discovery growth patterns in
the tusks of those who lived around the
Antarctic Circle showed annual marks of
stress that are very similar to what we
see in modern day animals that go into
hibernation those researchers
hypothesized that this might be evidence
of hibernation in some of our oldest
mammalian ancestors
the ability to hibernate seems strongly
related to the way reptiles manage their
body temperatures and metabolisms which
is completely different from how mammals
do it in Popular Science we think of
reptiles as being cold-blooded but the
technical term for them is ectotherms
this means that they can't produce their
own body heat and instead rely on the
external temperature that's why you'll
see lizards and snakes and alligators
basking in the Sun or moving slowly when
the temperature is cold
there are some big advantages to this
strategy they require a lot less food to
power their metabolisms and they can
basically shut down their bodies when
it's cold and survive for long periods
without sustenance many species even
have bouts of daily torpor which is a
little like hibernation but lasts for
much shorter periods and doesn't disrupt
the body quite so much
warm-blooded mammals on the other hand
are endotherms who generate their own
body heat through metabolic processes
this means we can get up and go no
matter the temperature but we also have
to eat a lot more and we have a harder
time surviving cold weather and long
stretches without food so how did our
ancient ancestors evolve from being
ectotherms into endotherms it's a
transition that would have taken a huge
increase in metabolism and doesn't seem
likely to have happened all at once
researchers now think there would have
been an intermediate step something like
the listrosaurus that was an endotherm
but could still change its body
temperature during periods of cold
weather or food scarcity in other words
hibernation could be a holdover from the
days of being ectotherms a reptilian
Remnant from the past that many
creatures still use today
and today reptiles are still some of the
most interesting examples of hibernators
using extreme techniques to allow them
to survive in situations where any other
animal would certainly die
some of the best hibernators among the
ectotherms are freshwater turtles like
the painted turtle and the Snapping
Turtle though technically their winter
torpor is known as brumation because
these reptiles live at Northern
latitudes where Winter can include
freezing temperatures they've had to
come up with some incredible adaptations
to make it through the cold season
when the weather starts getting icy both
species will head for shelter at the
bottom of lakes and ponds once there
they decrease their metabolisms
significantly and begin absorbing
whatever oxygen is left in the water
through a process known as cloacal
respiration AKA butt breathing
the cloaca is an orifice used for waste
removal and laying eggs and adjacent to
it are sac-like areas that are filled
with blood vessels when the turtles push
water into these sacs the papillae
absorb the oxygen almost like gills in
some species of turtle this type of
breathing can account for more than 50
percent of the oxygen they get while
swimming but if the winter lasts long
enough and the body of water remains
covered in ice for a long time
eventually the oxygen in the water will
run out which means not even butt
breathing will allow the turtles to get
any air this is when snapping turtles
and painted turtles depress their
metabolisms even further with their
heart beating only once every 5 to 10
minutes
this is slow and their cells are barely
getting enough oxygen to create energy
in the form of ATP but then they do
something remarkable they switch to
anaerobic respiration this means that
their metabolism is using glucose for
energy without requiring oxygen
we can do anaerobic respiration but by
no means can it power our whole body to
Keep Us Alive it's far less efficient
than aerobic respiration in part because
it leads to a massive buildup of lactic
acid in the blood this could kill the
turtles if not for a handy trick that
comes from having shells
the turtles are able to pull calcium and
magnesium carbonates from their shells
to neutralize the lactic acid protecting
themselves from harm
thanks to the combination of all these
abilities painted turtles and snapping
turtles are almost always perfectly fine
after a long winter although they can
still freeze to death if their bodies
are covered in ice for too long
with butt breathing and an ectothermic
metabolism these turtles have winter all
figured out but how do mammals survive
similarly harsh conditions sure they
don't need to butt breathe but they
still need to eat to keep their bodies
warm right how can such an energy
demanding creature simply shut down for
months at a time
unlike reptiles warm-blooded mammals
generally need lots of food to fuel
their metabolism especially big mammals
like bears brown bears need to eat about
5 000 calories a day so how can they
survive a winter without eating one part
of this is simple when they're preparing
for winter hibernation their calorie
intake jumps to about 20 000 calories a
day this helps them gain enough weight
to survive The Long Winter ahead
then once the bear enters their winter
Den they go for as long as a hundred
days without eating drinking exercising
urinating or defecating but unlike other
hibernators their internal temperature
only drops about 5 degrees Celsius and
they still occasionally move around
scientists have argued over whether
bears are true hibernators because this
looks so different than what's seen in
smaller mammals but a bear's heart rate
Slows To only four beats per minute and
their oxygen consumption drops by 75
percent so they're clearly still slowing
their metabolism down in a way that
looks just like hibernation
it seems that the problem with reducing
their body temperature so drastically
would be in warming themselves back up
there's such large animals that the
energetic cost is much higher than for
bats or squirrels that said they still
have some wild tricks for surviving The
Long Winter
while humans experience bone thinning
and muscle wasting with prolonged
periods of bed rest bears are able to
shut down the genes involved with the
breakdown of bone while in hibernation
this means they emerge from hibernation
weighing a lot less than when they
started but most of that weight is fat
not muscle and bone
on the other end of the spectrum from
bears are the Arctic ground squirrels
since they live in Canada Alaska and
Siberia they spend about seven months of
the year in nests buried below the
tundra
their body temperature falls to the
lowest level ever measured in any mammal
as low as negative 2.9 degrees Celsius
and when their plasma was sampled during
this frigid temperature researchers
found it had remained liquid despite not
having any anti-freeze chemicals in it
how is it possible for their very liquid
blood to not freeze at these below
freezing temperatures scientists have
hypothesized that they use supercooling
a process in which water goes below
freezing temperatures without forming
ice because there are no impurities to
start the crystallization process
but the squirrels don't stay in deep
hibernation for the entire winter
they go through inter-bought arousals
every two to three weeks shivering their
body temperature back up to 36.4 degrees
Celsius which lasts for about 12 hours
hibernating mammals expend about 70
percent of their energy stores for these
brief periods of arousal which help them
regulate normal body functions like
Bears Arctic ground squirrels come out
of hibernation without any muscle
wasting or brain damage which has led
scientists to wonder could we harness
some of the same tricks and apply them
to humans
for those of us who don't love freezing
during the winter months hibernation
might sound like an ideal way to get
through the cold weather but the
possibilities for human hibernation go
far beyond comfort and convenience
imagine what might be possible with long
distance space travel if Rockets didn't
have to be equipped with so much food
and water for astronauts because they'd
be in hibernation for most of the voyage
it could help them avoid interpersonal
conflicts and the mental strain of being
in a tiny metal box for months at a time
and it might even have health benefits
too
researchers found that rats placed in a
medically induced torpor experienced
less harm from radiation which could be
a promising development for humans
and if we could avoid brain damage as
well as muscle and bone loss like other
hibernating mammals that would be a huge
development for astronauts who already
deal with some of those problems on
relatively short space missions
while this concept might sound like
something out of Science Fiction it's
already being adapted in more limited
ways for medical purposes by cooling the
body and the blood of patients doctors
are able to perform more extreme heart
surgery without killing the individual
this therapeutic hypothermia can protect
the brain from damage caused by reduced
oxygen and allows patients to make a
faster recovery and there are even some
examples of people who have survived
prolonged freezing such as a hiker who
was found after 24 days of exposure and
whose body temperature had dropped to 22
degrees Celsius or 77 degrees Fahrenheit
his body had entered a state of torpor
and after being found he was able to
make a full recovery
and just as it is for bears and Arctic
ground squirrels the keys to hibernation
May lie hidden in our genome if
hibernation is a Remnant from our
ancient mammalian ancestors most experts
agree that it's an ability that most
mammals have simply lost over time the
genetic underpinnings may still very
much be in our DNA by sequencing and
understanding the genomes of today's
hibernators scientists are getting
closer to understanding how they
activate the groups of genes needed for
hibernation
this all offers a tantalizing
possibility not only that we may be able
to travel further into the solar system
but also that we could extend our lives
and survive Strokes heart attacks and
severe injuries if little primates like
dwarf lemurs can do it and enormous
mammals like Bears can do it who's to
say that it will never be possible for
humans maybe one day we'll be able to
pass the winter away from the quiet
peacefulness of our own hibernation pods
but we can only begin to guess at what
comes next for our species if we
understand our evolutionary Journey what
our future holds is shaped by our past a
past so bizarre that it caused humans to
become basically the weirdest animals to
ever walk the earth we're the only
creatures to walk on two legs besides
kangaroos sort of the only primate to
lose basically all of its fur the only
animal to throw but to speak to write
down its language where an animal that
became so smart with brain so giant that
we basically shouldn't be able to exist
and yet here we are why did we get so
weird how did we diverge so drastically
from the other primates why did
Evolution Select us to become emotional
walking monkeys equipped with a
supercomputer for a brain the complexity
of human evolution blows my mind and is
the subject of our new series becoming
human available exclusively on nebula
this is our most ambitious project yet
and we wouldn't have been able to do it
without nebula nebula is a streaming
platform that was created by us by the
educational YouTube content creators who
are tired of worrying about if their
ideas would suit the YouTube algorithm's
desires sometimes the content we want to
make is experimental too long too short
or contains themes that would get it
demonetized instantly on YouTube
sometimes we want to make content that
doesn't exactly fit on our regular
YouTube channels
or sometimes like in the case of
becoming human we want to make a
beautiful Standalone piece nebula is our
baby and by signing up you are directly
supporting us getting to watch all of
your favorite content ad free and also
getting access to tons of exclusive
content becoming human is one example of
many great original shows other
noteworthy examples are City beautiful's
great cities series which explores the
most important moments of the greatest
cities on Earth or Neo's under exposure
series which brings to light the dark
aspects of important historical moments
and on top of original content if you
sign up with my link you get free access
to nebula classes where our creators
host classes on how to make the content
you know and love all the classes are
taught by the creators on nebula so you
can learn how Alex the low spec gamer
makes videos on a budget or how foreign
tells stories or how Patrick Willems
makes movies your favorite creators
teaching you how they create
if you've ever wanted to become a
content creator or video maker or are
just curious how it all gets done this
is a great place to start so if you sign
up for nebula using the link below you
can get nebula for a little over two and
a half dollars per month or thirty
dollars for the entire year a portion of
this subscription fee goes directly to
us and the rest goes towards building
this platform to become the best
streaming platform out there for viewers
and creators